the charges I'm most concerned uh
concerned with are the document charges
because they're pretty cut and dry he
had them they're at the house they're
classified or National Defense
information
um they gave them a chance they're going
to argue we gave them months we you know
we had to open up a grand jury
investigation to get these documents we
did a search warrant we look at all of
these ridiculous acts we have to take to
get these documents back that's what
they're going to say the um the January
6th stuff I mean Jacksonville has a hard
on for Trump at this point to be honest
with you but the thing that worries me
as well is that I know how the feds
operate right and just for the audience
to understand the feds have the luxury
of taking the cases they know that they
can win and the cases that they want
most U.S attorney's offices have a 90
plus success rate with their cases yeah
like the southern district of New York
Etc these big districts they don't lose
because it's the DA's offices that
typically lose because they take on
disorderly charged disorderly conduct
they take all the dumb charges but the
feds take the big sexy cases